RIGHT I'M
GOING TO ASK EVERYONE TO TAKE
THEIR SEATS. GOOD MORNING THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. WE ARE
MEETING THIS MORNING TO TAKE UP
TO TEN ITEMS FOR- FOUR VOTE
ONLY. THESE ARE BILLS THAT THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARD
TESTIMONY ON YESTERDAY. THAT
HEARING WAS TELEVISED
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES THE FINAL VOTES ON
THESE BILLS WERE NOT TELEVISED
YESTERDAY. THEREFORE IN ORDER
TO MAINTAIN TRANSPARENCY FOR
THE PUBLIC WE ARE CONVENING THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH THIS
MORNING TO ENSURE THAT THE
FINAL VOTES ARE CAST. AND
RECORDED AND AVAILABLE THROUGH
OUR MEDIA ARCHIVE. SO WE WILL
THEN AGAIN GO THROUGH OUR
AGENDA FOR VOTE ONLY AND- AND
THEN- WILL THEN IN TURN-
ACTUALLY. GOOD QUESTION. OKAY
SO- IF WE TAKE EACH ITEM I'LL
NEED A MOTION AND THEN WILL
CALL THE ROLL SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH- WHAT WAS- ON THE ITEM ON
THE AGENDA ON FOR THURSDAY JUNE
TENTH WE'LL START WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER DAVIES IS
THERE A MOTION SOME OF THE WIND
OKAY- THAT SENATOR ROCK MOTIONS
DO PASSES AMENDED BUT FIRST THE
MANDAN REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S EGGMAN.
EGGMAN EIGEN SOLACE CONSEILLERS
I GROW FINE GROVE I HER TADO
FOR TITLE I LEAVE IT HI LIVE I
LIVE ALONE HI THE MON I ROSS
ROTH IRA RUBIO RUBIN I WINNER
HI WINNER I. THAT BILL IS OUT
TEN ZERO NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE OF THAT. I NUMBER.
POLITICS I NUMBER FOR EIGHTY
FOUR NINE BY THEM OF OUR- THIS
OUR MOTION. OKAY- I THINK
THAT'S AN ADMIN YES NINE
EMOTIONS PASS. SECTOR OF
CONSULTANT CALL THE- PAN I CAN
I MELINDA. AIKMAN EGGMAN
ARKANSAS. CONSULT I. NO GROWTH
IN HER TAUGHT. FOR TWO I LEAVE
A HI LEAVE A MON. THE MOON IRA
SORRY ROSS I RUBIO HI RUBY I
WINNER I WINNER I. OKAY THAT
BILL IS NINE ACTUALLY LET ME
TAKE A PAUSE HERE. THE BERNIE.
ALL RIGHT I APOLOGIZE TO THE
COMMITTEE- WE FIRST YOU NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CAN TAKE UP
THE VOTES MY APOLOGIES SORRY
THIS IS PRESENTED TO REDO A
COMMITTEE HEARING ALL RIGHT
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM CAN HEAR
HER HANDS HERE MELINDA IS A
COMMON HERE EIGHT MEN HERE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE GROWTH
HERE GROVE HERE HER TADO YEAH
RETIRE HERE LEAVE US. HERE LIVE
HERE LEE MON HI HERE LEE MONA
HERE ROTH YOUR ROTH HERE RUBIO.
RUBIO. HERE WINNER HERE. K.
OKAY A QUORUM NOW A STAB I. WE
ARE GOING TO REDO THOSE PRIDE
TO PAY VOTES SOMETHING CARD
CORNISH YOU- SO- WE'LL GO BACK
TO I NUMBER TWO EIGHTY EIGHTY
ONE SUMMER. IT'S A NEW BY
CENTER ROCK YOU PASS AND ENDED
FIRST REFER TO ME I JUDICIARY.
AND SO ON PLEASE CALL THE PAN
HI CAN I MELINDA. AIKMAN BUT A
MAN I CAN SEE. I CONSEILLERS I
GROW FINE GROVE I TADO. HI FOR
TITLE I A LEAVE A HIGHLY THANK
YOU LIMA I. ROSS. ROSS I RUBIO
I WILL BE ABLE A WINNER ALL
RIGHT WINNER I THAT BILL IS OUT
TO ZERO NEXT TIME I'M NUMBER.
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY NINE BY
SUMMER BY HIGH AND IT'S MOVED
BY CENTER. COULD PLEASE CALL
ROLL PAN- HI CAN I MELINDA'S
AIKMAN BY ADMIN CAN SELL HI
CONSOLES I GROVE NO GROVE NO
HER TADO. I HER TITLE I LLEVA
HI LEAVE A LEAVE MY- HI LIMO
FIVE. HI ROTH IRA. FIVE RUBIO I
WE HI WEINER I. FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI AN HIGH MELINDA'S AIKMAN
AIKMAN I CAN SOLID SIDE
CONSOLES I GROWTH. GROVE KNOWN
HER TADO. HURTADO I. LEIVA.
LEAVE A HIGHLY MON HI LIAM I
ROTH ROTH IRA RUBIO HI RUBIO I
WINNER WINNER I. THAT BILL IS
OUT NINE ONE- THE NEXT BILL IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY EIGHT BY SUMMER RECORDS
SILVA IS EMOTION. THE MOVE OKAY
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ROB
EMOTIONS THE PATH OF PRE BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I. GONZALEZ HI AND SOLIS
I'D GROVE. GROVE I HER TADO I
RETURNED I LAID BACK HI LEAVE A
HIGHLY MON BY LEE MORAN I ROSS
HI ROSS I RUBIO. RUBIO. I
WINNER RIGHT WINGER HI. THAT IS
OUT TEN ZERO. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE BISA MEMINTA SYRIAN IS OUR
MOTION. SOME OF ITS MOVE BY A
CENTER LAID OUT THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED FIRST REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS- CANCELED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN I
MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN I.
GONZALEZ HI CONSEILLERS A GROVE
HI GROVE I HER TADO. FOR TOTAL
I LEAVE LISA. HI LISA RILEY MON.
THE MOON I. ROSS. ROSS HI RUBIO
HI RUBIO A WINNER ALL RIGHT YOU
KNOW I. THAT BUILD OUT TEN ZERO
AND FINALLY- WE HAVE OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THOSE ARE-
ITEM NUMBER- SIX EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO BY SIMILAR RULE
WOULD ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY THE- SIMPLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE EIGHTY FIFTEEN
EIGHTY ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY THIS
TIME THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. I AM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER
CHECKING. MISSING OUT AND I
SORRY ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER
COM LAGER. IS OUR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO MOVED. OKAY
GUYS MOVE BY SENATOR LEYVA A
CONSULTANT- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I CAN I CAN I MELINDA'S
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I. GONZALEZ
CONSOLES I GROW GROVE I HER
TADO I DON'T I LLEVA HI LISA HI
LEE MOON. THE MOON IRA ROTH IRA
OR ROTH IRA RUBIO. RUBIO I
WINNER WINNER HI. THE CONTENT
CALENDARS OUT TEN ZERO BUT THAT
THAT CONCLUDES THE AGENDA OF
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH- PRECIADO
EVERYONECOMING IN THIS MORNING
FOR THIS- I ALSO WANTED STAFF
AT THIS HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.